the brand new coach of the los angeles
chargers by way of
the los angeles rams where he was the
defensive coordinator it's brandon
stanley coach staley welcome to the
program how are you i'm doing great mike
thanks for having me
hey i have to start with a very critical
area of questioning and we only ask the
the hardest hitting of questions here in
the pft universe
i was impressed that there was no tie
worn by you during the introductory
press conference i'm a firm believer no
ties by coaches because they don't wear
ties anymore on the sideline how close
did you come to wearing a tie for your
introductory press conference not very
close um besides being a huge greg
popovich fan um
a direct um
order from dean spanos that we are not a
thai operation here so just following uh
following my boss's orders but uh you
know
very lucky that way
well that's good and that's the right
approach it just looks unnatural it
feels unnatural and it's your
introduction to the fan base to the
media and by all indications you hit a
home run with what you did on thursday
and you hit a home run with the job you
got look every coach of a team in the
nfl is going to say he got the best job
available you got the best job available
tell us why you believe it truly is the
best job that was available this cycle
you know mike i think just possibility i
think that there's just a lot of
possibility with this team being you
know in this city uh being at the
beginning of something i think we're at
the beginning of something with the
chargers and then you know certainly you
know what everybody is uh well aware of
this you know quarterback that we have
justin herbert is just such an exciting
young player what he did expressing
himself to the nfl you know that's just
such a big component of the of the job
and then we have a really good nucleus
of players you know um mike you know on
all you know three phases you know got a
really good mix of youth and experience
you know production um both ways you
know with young players and proven
players so i think that there's a really
nice blend here
and i think that you know moving forward
we just have a really good opportunity i
want to back up a step because usually
when a football coach invokes another
coach has some sort of inspiration or
source of admiration it's a football
coach not a basketball coach what is it
about greg popovich that makes you
want to kind of follow in his example
i just i think he's so global i think he
has command over just a lot besides just
basketball just leadership um i just
i've loved how he brings people together
just have followed you know when you
think about the spurs you think about
tony parker and manoj nobly and then tim
duncan there's like these three people
from all over the world that he brought
together and i think just the way he had
a vision for you know the players um on
that team bringing them together from
all over the world and how that they
were going to play they have a very
unique style and then just his coaching
tree the people in the nba that have
kind of learned from him and you know
you see what uh he's doing you know on
his staff becky hammond you know just
like i just think this guy's so ahead of
everybody and he's just refreshing
besides being an amazing coach i think
just his leadership uh just really huge
fan and of all i'm always trying to
learn from him
he's never afraid to say what's on his
mind is that an area where you believe
you will emulate coach popovich
well i think uh greg has certainly
earned the right to be that way you know
i think if you went back a ways you know
um i think you you know you certainly
have to earn that you know i think he
definitely has but i think that that's
what's so refreshing about him and i
think that's why he's endeared himself
to his players because even though he's
telling you what's on his mind you know
that there's a deeper deeper level of a
relationship that allows him to speak
his mind and i think that that's what's
always made him really unique
so i'm now envisioning a turn by brandon
staley at some point he's very nice and
friendly and accommodating with the
media now once he has some success he's
going to turn into kind of a prickly and
sullen
figure when dealing with the media just
like popovich is that what we can look
forward to i don't think so i think
everybody's got to be themselves mike
you know
i try to tell people you know everyone's
saying hey are you tired yet you know i
think stamina is a good trait of mine
you know i think i have stamina and i
think that i have respect for people uh
who do a job and you know i think that i
think interacting with the media is such
a
integral part of being a head coach and
i think what that relationship means to
me is you know you guys are the ones
that you know give the fans the
information and i think that that's a
special thing and you have to take it
seriously so all i'm going to try and do
is be myself and do the best i can
well i i watched a lot of your press
conference yesterday and you were
destined to be part of this world in
some capacity the image of the little
kid with the newspaper and the cup of
coffee reading about sports and soaking
in everything he could i was the same
way they wouldn't let me drink coffee
though i was i was eating frosted flakes
instead it was the same idea you soak it
all in you love it you want to be part
of it you find a way to be part of it
and i think that that that's one of the
reasons why
you strike me as somebody who has
immense respect for everyone who's
involved in it because at the core we've
all got that same love of the sport
yeah i think it's what brings people
together i think that's why i love the
nfl so much is because people that are
in the nfl regardless if you're a player
coach
in the media it's just such a
challenging profession you know it's so
challenging and that's what i think the
people that are in it know what it
requires and i think that that's what
brings you together and what makes it so
amazing so
i think anytime you're a part of this
fraternity whether you're man or woman
like i said player coach doesn't matter
media
you have something special and and and i
i'm a big fan of that and that's why i
love the nfl so much if i were able to
get brandon staley from 2016 on the
phone right now defensive coordinator at
john carroll and explain to him where he
would be
in five years what would he say
i don't think he would be as surprised
as everybody else i think that
mike it doesn't make sense to a lot of
people but i think the people that were
with me in 2016 my players our coaches
the people that were with me my family
i think that they would have bet on it
maybe not this quickly
but i bet you they bet that i could do
it
and i've always had that belief in
myself because i've always known what
i've invested in my game
and that 2016 defense that i was a part
of it john carroll that's as good of a
defense as i've ever been a part of and
i've been a part of two number one
defenses in the nfl uh and that was a
special group of guys and you know i had
a strong sense that i could do it at
this level
and i think that when i got to chicago
mike you know in 2017 it kind of
solidified my belief system
and then you know i think what you do is
over the course of the next four years
then you're just you're getting ready
you know i mean like you're ready but
then you know when you get that
opportunity you're ready to go with it
and i'm fortunate to be around a lot of
great people coaches uh players and uh
you know so thankful for all of them to
make it happen because you know that
that that's why i'm here when you say
that going to chicago in 2017 solidified
your belief system i read that as
you saw that what you thought about
football and how you would coach
football and how you would teach
football would work at the highest
possible level is that the moment where
it kind of fell together for you that
you know what i belong here and i'm
gonna make it here yeah i think mikey
you just hit it because there is that
transition that's real like there is
that transition okay now i'm coaching a
pro player and that relationship is
different but it's still a relationship
which you know i feel like is a strength
of mine and i think once i got to see it
for myself and be with the you know
great coaches like a vic fangio you know
meant so much to me a guy that's seen so
much and ed donatell you know john fox
all these people that mean a lot to me i
think once i got there with those guys
and saw you know what the nfl really was
like uh you know that was a big
confidence builder for anyone who has a
high degree of success in any field
especially a public field like football
there's a point where
the fire lights the desire is born do
you remember when
you
and maybe it never happened consciously
but is there a time in your life where
you you personally kind of flipped that
switch in your being that you were going
to end up in a spot like this
yeah mike i think you know as you may be
aware i had great parents who were my
heroes and i think that from a young age
they were training they were you know
uh my brothers and i to be like that you
know to be the best versions of
ourselves to be competitors uh to invest
all of our being into you know achieving
our dreams so i think that we were off
to a great start
i think after i got done with my cancer
stuff um
i think that that was kind of a
slingshot you know because when you get
to the other side of it uh i think that
there is a confidence there's a strength
that you have and i think after that
experience i said
i know that i can go to where i want to
go i know i can do it you know i just
have to get going to doing so and i
think
after that experience it was kind of
really a slingshot uh met my wife and
you know just things started to happen
from there and it's great that you talk
about that so openly i praised ron
rivera the washington coach
during his bout for being an inspiration
for the folks who are going through it
but i also think someone who's been
through it who's beaten it and who's
used it as you say as a slingshot can be
a great inspiration to someone who's
going through
the rigors of treatment it can be hell
it can be worse
than than dying from the disease some of
the things people go through with
chemotherapy and the dread of the next
round of chemotherapy so it's great that
you you speak so openly about it and
share those experiences because i really
do think even 14 years after the fact if
my math is right and it may not be it
still can inspire people who are going
to be dealing with it now and moving
forward yeah it stays with you you know
i hope uh you know seeing ron you know
going through that this year and knowing
some people that know him what it did
for someone like me that's already been
past it but just you know uh you know
there's just that empathy and and i
think that that's something that's uh
you know awesome about having this
platform is that hopefully there's young
kids boys and girls maybe there's people
that are older that are going through it
uh just you give them that just that
little bit more you know that little bit
of hope that they need that little bit
of boost you know to finish you know
what they've started because that's most
of it just believing that you can do it
and hanging tough and you know having
that support system and those examples
to look at and you know i i you know ron
just uh just an amazing job this year
you know with that team
you know taking that team to the
playoffs and just transforming that
culture
and what better embodiment of everything
than what he was going through you
mentioned your siblings and i heard you
say yesterday you've got a twin brother
is your twin brother identical or
fraternal
we're fraternal uh look like brothers
but not like twins so like if you decide
one day just like during a preseason
game or just for fun to let him show up
and coach for a day would anyone notice
i i think they'd notice pretty quick
yeah i think they know by his decisions
or by what he looks like maybe both they
my brother they may like my brother a
lot more than me my brother's really
sharp so i you know that would be
dangerous for me because they they may
want to replace me with with my brother
so
who's giving you the best advice for the
job that you now have
uh i think my wife you know i think my
wife gave me the best advice uh she gave
me a lot of confidence going into it and
she said don't you
don't you be somebody you're not you
know and you know just make sure that
you express yourself um exactly the way
you feel
and and that'll be good enough you know
and i think that going into this season
going into these interviews uh you know
she really gave me that that extra wink
that that extra smile um
that gives you all the all the lift that
you need so
i'd have to go with aim
give me give me an idea of what your
normal work day is going to look like by
way of when does the alarm go off when
do you roll out of bed how many times do
you hit the snooze button when do you
get in and how long are you going to be
at the building on a normal day
you know mike i think uh
that's going to be one of the things i
need to do quickly is establish a rhythm
i wouldn't say that we're there yet uh
right now
but i think that the one thing i value
in this life uh is sleep uh because i
don't think any of us are very good
without it so uh you know i would rather
go to sleep earlier and be up a little
bit earlier but i am definitely not one
of these four o'clock
you know people that's not me uh but i
do like to get my morning started get a
lift and get a get a run in and and then
get my day started you know because to
me that that's that's how i operate it
the best is is get to sleep a little bit
earlier
get to wake up a little bit earlier get
a workout in and then get going
defensive coach wildly successful former
quarterback now an nfl head coach how
involved will you be in the crafting
execution and coaching of the offense as
the head coach of the chargers yeah mike
just i think it's so important that your
team is aligned in all three phases of
the game and i know that people make a
lot of that with a defensive coach you
know what are you going to do for this
young quarterback you know and um you
know a lot of the guys that i've kind of
patterned my game after you know uh
jimmy johnson uh bill parcells of mike
tomlin pete carroll tony dungy bill
belichick yo i think what those guys
represent to me because they all had
quarterbacks you know that were young
uh i think what those guys represent
is alignment with the leadership of
their team and their system continuity
of their system like hey
as a defensive coach you know that this
guy is unique
and i can give him this double education
that can help his game
you know really really really take off
uh but as a defensive coach what you
know a player needs is that continuity
you know so regardless of who's running
that offense because as you know with
success comes transition
that the offense
all right is really coming through you
not somebody else you're not
subcontracting a side of the ball you
know they can be taken and then all of a
sudden it evaporates you know so i think
that that's what i was so excited about
mike was to be able to hire someone that
has my vision and a shared vision for
offense and knowing that we have to
uniquely shape it for justin because you
know it's going to center around him and
i think that
that is what i am looking forward to
doing
so just to put it in more basic terms
this is going to be closer to
sean payton and drew brees then say mike
zimmer and kirk cousins where right or
wrong not being judgmental zimmer hands
the keys to his offensive coordinator
and as it turns out when you have good
offensive coordinators they leave to
become head coaches whereas when you've
got a coach who's tied to the
quarterback you do have that continuity
it sounds like you're going to be closer
to peyton even though you come as a
defensive coordinator not as an
offensive coordinator yeah and i think i
think mike when you look historically
like sean you know who who is his
biggest mentor bill parcells you know
and what parcells and belichick have
been able to do with the offensive side
of the ball is have continuity on that
side of the ball that's why bill
parcells got all those quarterbacks to
play so well sims hostetler vinnie tessa
verdi quincy carrier tony romo like
wherever he went like they played well
you know and it's the same thing with
belichick you know he's been in cleve uh
you know in new england for 20 years but
it's you know charlie weiss josh
mcdaniels bill o'brien back to josh
mcdaniels and they've kept that system
the same for tom brady and i think
that's the takeaway for me is that you
have to craft it around that guy and
keep it uh you know keep it so that that
quarterback becomes the system if that
makes sense oh it does make sense and
it's and i think it's something that
will be very refreshing and and also uh
relaxing for chargers fans who may have
looked at this as the beginning of a
revolving door of offenses and offensive
coordinators because justin herbert is
going to get guys hired and your
presence is going to get guys hired and
you're going to have every one two three
years a new coordinator but it sounds
like the offensive vision will be the
same and it doesn't hurt to have
justin herbert who in my estimation is
already a top five guy i mean talk about
a great job to fall into not that you
fell into it you earned it but this guy
i don't think people realize because the
chargers on national tv a lot how good
this guy is
yeah justin's really special and i think
that mike you can't minimize the way he
played this year global pandemic no
off-season
you know no training camp pre-season
this guy gets thrust into the starting
role really on game week and to be able
to perform the way he did i think says
more about his makeup than his physical
gifts you know because i think there are
a lot of physically gifted guys playing
quarterback uh maybe not as gifted as
justin because they're not many guys six
six that you know have that mobility
that arm strength and you know all the
physical gifts that he has but i just
think what's under the hood of justin is
really what makes him special and if you
look back to oregon been through four
you know systems in college and and you
know mike covering the league as a
quarterback it's the guys that can go
through things you know and come on the
other side of it those are the ones that
are standing at the end you know
competing for championships and i think
that certainly uh we have a guy that you
know we can say every game we feel good
about our chances
one of the things that chargers are
going to be going through with is the
idea that the chiefs are in the division
with patrick mahomes twice per year
competing with them give me just a quick
snapshot of what your approach
will be will it be try to outscore them
or will it be do everything you can to
hold them under 20 points
i think you if you look at the history
of the league with with guys as special
as patrick is and he's
i mean i think it's obvious to everybody
that he's one of those guys that people
are going to remember
uh it's very hard to hold guys like that
down you know in big games and i think
that the the analytics of the league and
you know certainly trending in the last
i would say five to seven years would
tell you that you better score more than
24 points to beat pat mahomes
you know when i was in the league or
when i was in the division with denver
there was like this stat like through
two years that you know there's only two
teams that held him under 24 you know
and so uh you know that's got to be a
big part of your mission statement
against him uh is being able to score
enough and then try to take away his
turns you know limit possessions uh and
play a team game you know to uh minimize
you know the impact they can that he can
have on the game and so uh you know but
you hit it on the head you have to be
able to score in this league you know
against these premium players these four
guys that are playing this weekend in
the final four you better be able to
score uh against these guys um
you know because you know they're that
special
last one for you and i appreciate your
time i know you've been talking a lot
you'll be carrying around lozenges all
weekend long after all the talking
you've had to do but you come from the
rams to the chargers two teams in
different conferences they play each
other once per year in games that count
but there is a competition there and the
chargers have kind of been for whatever
reason the little brothers in the la
market how conscious of you are that
coming in and what's what's your plan
for changing that and making the
chargers the top team in the market
you know mike i think number one i'm
excited to be in a market like los
angeles i think that if you're a
competitor you want to be where the
action is and i think la is one of the
great sports cities in the world let
alone the united states and i think uh
you know what i'm hoping to bring mike
to the chargers is we're not really
focused on our competition you know
we're focused on the chargers you know
and that's what to me the great
competitors i've been around they're not
worried about anybody else they're
worried about their own game and i think
that's what we got to do with our team
with our organization i think that
that's what will resonate to our fans is
we're not trying to compare ourselves to
anybody you know we're trying to be the
chargers and i think that we got a lot
of work to do as you know and and we're
excited to get started with it i said
that was the last one but i'm a former
lawyer so i always have one more
five years from now when we consider
five years ago where brandon staley was
five years from now where's brandon
staley going to be
well i i hope i'm 43 years old hopefully
i make it uh you know certainly uh but
you know i i think that
a big goal of mine you know starts with
establishing a program of consistency
i think that any elite competitor wants
to be you know known as a consistent com
you know performer and i think that for
the chargers uh to be viewed that way
then we're going to have to beat
all these great teams you know in our
side of things starting in our division
and we have to have a brand of football
that stands the test of time you know
and i think in the nfl that's really
difficult to achieve
because it's so competitive but i know
that we can do it and so in five years
i'm hoping that teams will say that is
one of the elite teams that's one of the
elite franchises in the nfl and that
they do things the right way and that
they're not going anywhere anytime soon
well you got the right quarterback and
it looks like the chargers also have the
right coach and we appreciate your time
all the best to you and your family
congratulations on an incredible week
and good luck moving forward thanks a
lot mike great to meet you
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports